- Welcome to Rostovzteff lecture,
sponsored by the Rostovzteff Fund
in the Classics Department at Yale.
It's lovely to have such a large
and such an international audience.
It's the silver lining of Zoom.
So I'm gonna speak very briefly just to
sort of introduce the lecture.
And some of you have
heard this story before,
but when I was first chair happily,
it hasn't been all along.
But the first time in 2007,
our wonderful administrative
assistant came to me one day
and she said, "do what
this Rost, Rost, Rost
this new fund is?"
And I said, "I do not."
So we looked and we learned
how to pronounce the name
and discovered that Rostovzteff's widow
had left us a substantial amount of money
in a proper endowment and with nothing,
no strings on it,
except that it was to support
the teaching and research
of ancient history and archeology at Yale.
And ancient history at Yale in 2007
was not nearly as strong as it is now.
And it seemed to me that a
good thing to do would be
to advertise and to give split
some wind under its wings.
So I started this lectureship
and then later a Rostovzteff
traveling fellowship in archeology,
which has supported graduate students
from a number of different
departments over the years.
And of course, ancient history at Yale
is now flourishing and
Joe Manning, Noel Lenski,
Andrew Johnson and Jessica
Lamont all work together every
year to pick the lecturer
and to do activities around
the annual lecture.
So you all know who Mikhail
Ivanovich Rostovtzeff was
and how important his work has been
in shaping the various ways
of doing ancient history and archeology.
He came to Yale by a circuitous route,
the collapse of the Romanov empire
and the triumph of Leninist bolshevism,
drove him from Russia in
1918, accompanied by his wife.
He spent two years in Oxford in 1920.
He was offered a chair at
the University of Madison
University of Wisconsin, Madison,
where he remained for what he termed
the happiest years of his life.
In 1925, he came to Yale where
he was made Sterling
Professor of Ancient History
and classical archeology.
And in 1927, he undertook and directed
the Yale excavations at Dura-Europos
which of course had a profound
impact on the composition of
the classics department here
for the next few decades.
And on archeology of the,
we don't call it late
antiquity at that point, do we,
but of the empire and going
on from the fall of Dura
for many many years.
William Calder wrote of him in the,
"The Biographical Dictionary
of North American Classicists"
said he showed Americans
how to get things done.
He frightened most of them.
He never became say the
lecturer president of the APA,
or even chairman at Yale,
but he was (speaks in foreign language)
in the sense that nothing
will be the same after him.
And there are a few of those
of whom that may be said.
Tonight's lecturer is one
of whom that might be said,
Jessica Lamont we'll introduce him,
but I want to record a personal
pleasure that this year's
lecturer is Roger Bagnall,
who was a terrific guidance
and support to me when we were
rebuilding the Yale NELC department.
So with no further ado, I turn
it over to Jessica Lamont.
- Thank you so much, Chris.
Hi everyone my name is Jessica Lamont.
I'm an assistant professor
in the Department
of Classics here at Yale.
Am hellenist as Chris mentioned
in our combined program
in ancient history.
And it's really a pleasure
tonight to welcome
and introduce Roger Bagnall,
who has graciously stuck with
us as his lecture transformed
from an in-person event in which
she was meant to present on
a grand stage and then attend
to reception and a dinner
with real live humans into
this remote event on Zoom,
which at least comes with a big audience
from around the world.
So thank you, Roger for this,
and thanks to all of you in
attendance with us tonight.
So Roger was an undergraduate student
in the Department of
Classics here at Yale,
where he graduated with
various honors and distinctions
before going on to receive his MA and PhD
at the university of Toronto.
He spent the bulk of his career 33 years
as J professor of Greek
and Latin and professor
of history at Columbia University,
during which you served as
Dean of the Graduate School of
Arts and Sciences and chair
of the department of classics.
He then joined the NYU faculty in 2007
as a professor of ancient history
and the director of the Institute
for the study of the ancient world.
In many ways, Roger is the
ideal of Rostovtzeff lecturer
as he like Rostovtzeff is a titan
in the field of ancient history.
And he specializes in the
social and economic history
of the Hellenistic Roman
and late antique worlds.
Roger's work is also interdisciplinary
combining documentary
evidence, especially that from Papyri,
with archeological evidence
to aluminate complex social
histories and like Rostovtzeff said
Roger also undertakes
and directs field work.
Roger leads NYU's excavation
project at Amheida jointly
sponsored with Columbia
in the Dakhla in Egypt.
His recent book "An Oasis City"
presents some results from this work .
Now among Roger's other
well-known books are
"Egypt in Late Antiquity"
"Reading Papyri, Writing Ancient History,"
"The Oxford Handbook of Papyri"
and "Everyday Writing in
the Greco-Roman East."
And while his publications
are extensive and have been
extremely influential in
ancient history circles,
I thought I'd call attention
to a less well-known article or
Rogers written in the year 1986 called
"The Computer and Classical Research."
Now in this a 34 year old
article, which I read last night,
Roger takes readers through
the exciting potential
for research and learning
that the computer
could have for the future
of classical scholarship.
34 years ago, Roger
speculated on the benefits
that technology it might
one day have for our field,
from the existence of
machine readable files to
the dissemination of the
results of one's research.
Now I couldn't help,
but wish that past Roger
could see Roger tonight
here in the current moment,
presenting from his computer
to an audience across
the world, sharing images and texts
from his ongoing research
with all of us tonight.
So without further ado,
here's Roger Bagnall,
speak to us on the other caravan
cities, transport capital,
and inequality in the Egyptian oases.
Thank you.
- Thank you.
It is true that without technology,
I would just be having
dinner at home tonight,
which wouldn't be so bad, but
anyway, thank you very much,
Jessica and thank you to the
department for inviting me.
It is surely among the least
of the many dismal consequences
of the COVID-19 pandemic that I am unable
to be speaking today in
the Yale lecture hall
to a live audience.
I'm in fact in St. Louis
trying like most grandparents
that seems to help with my
grandchildren's remote schooling.
And yet I feel the loss of presence
when I was back for my 50th reunion,
two years ago, many memories came back
of my undergraduate formation
in the school of Rostovtzeff
Can I have the slide please, Joe.
It was a period of bitter struggle
in the classics department,
whether that legacy would
survive, but through it all,
I learned much about what it meant
to be an ancient historian
from Rostovtzeff academic hair
C. Bradford Wells and Wells's, students,
John Oates, and Alan Samuel,
both of whom had left
Yale before I graduated.
And also from Jerry Polete
not only from his teaching,
but from my two years of working for him
in the department slide collection,
which had a profound impact on my career,
it is a joy to see ancient
history archeology so strong
at Yale in this century,
Rostovtzeff's caravan cities
was published in 1932.
It was the translation of
a substantial rewriting
and expansion of a Russian
version of his travel sketches
published the year before.
And it was based on further
travel in the near east.
After the appearance
of the Russian version,
publishing must have moved faster
before modern technology intervened.
The preface tells us
that the choice of cities
was accidental based on
the state of preservation
of the ruins, Petra Jerash,
Pell Myra, and Dora.
Actually it is not an accident
that Damascus Aleppo mountain
were less susceptible to study.
Because they had modern cities
on top of the ancient sites,
Rostovtzeff's choice of what is today,
Jordan and Syria for his
travels was also a reflection
of his interests.
And of course of Yale's involvement
in the excavations at both
Dora and Jerash at the time.
The underlying premise of the
book and the source of the
concept of caravan cities
is that the ancient cities
of the near east were
never self-sufficient.
They always had to trade
supply their needs for goods,
not available locally.
Although some of this
trade could go by water.
Much of the interior of the
region could not be reached
except over land.
The cities studied in the book,
all met that criterion as indeed
would have those he omitted
Rostovtzeff thus began with
an emphasis on the needs
of producers and consumers and the role
of caravan trade in meeting those needs.
It is all the more striking to see
that in the remainder
of the historical survey
that opens the book and even more in the
succeeding chapters, the agency
and motives of producers,
consumers and merchants are largely elided
in favor of the role of government.
In effect, the economics of
the trade got little attention,
but a moment's thought most
show that only if the trade
economically viable with
those governments who cared,
how did the economics work and
what were the consequences?
By the time we get to Jerash
where Rostovtzeff admitted
that there was no direct
evidence of role for trade
in the city's obvious wealth.
Next slide, please.
The absence of any other
visible source of prosperity
was sufficient in his eyes to justify
the characterization of it
as a caravan city, the books,
origins and travel sketches
become increasingly clear
as it goes on.
Economic analysis is unusually
for Rostovtzeff barely present.
There is these near Eastern
travels did not include Egypt,
although he did visit
it on other occasions,
Egypt does not however,
entirely missing from caravan cities.
Rostovtzeff stresses,
the close connections
between Egypt and the near east from
at least the fourth millennium
BC on, but he saw correctly,
the transportation inside
Egypt was above all by water on
the Nile and so by the first
millennium, and indeed,
I would say earlier,
was its external trade,
which used particularly
the maritime routes
to the ports of the Levant.
He also pointed to the role
of Overland caravans and
connecting his caravan cities to Egypt,
mainly through the neck of land,
connecting the Nile valley to Sinai,
but no Egyptian city
figures as a caravan city
in his account, this is
perhaps not surprising
because the Egyptian cities
known to him were all
on the Mediterranean,
the Red Sea or the Nile.
Those with which I shall be
dealing were hardly known at the
time he wrote it is perhaps
telling that the word Oases does
not even figure in the index to the book.
One has to remember the
travel conditions of the era.
Rostovtzeff missed visiting
Petra two decades earlier
because quote, "it was
necessary to equip a caravan,
to find a guards, and
to obtain and give a day
from the Turkish officials," unquote,
he lauds the English who have
quote "like the Romans before
them brought order and safety,
good roads and new means
of transport" and of quote.
But Petra was relatively easy
to reach compared to the Oasis
of Egypt's Western desert, apart
from a few early explorers,
there was no archeology in
these oases before Ahmed Bakari
began work in the 1960s
and the Oases occupied the
most modest of places in
the ancient written sources
that were known in Rostovtzeff's time.
Next slide, please.
There are five principle Oases in
the Western desert of Egypt
warming an arc that begins with
Siwa in the north continues
through Bahariya and Farafra
in the middle and finishes
with Dakhla and Kharga.
The distances that stake are
large, even in modern terms,
about 300 kilometers from Paraitonion
modern Marsa Matruh on the coast to Siwa.
About 400 kilometers from Siwa to Bahariya
175 from Bahariya to Farafra
300 from Farafra to Dakhla
and just under 200 from Dakhla to Kharga.
Similarly distances from any
of them to the valley are vast
ranging from a low of about
200 kilometers from Bahariya
to Oxyrhynchus to 365
kilometers by the direct route
from Dakhla to the valley and
much the same from
Bahariya to modern Cairo
or ancient Memphis.
Siwa is in a class by itself, even one,
one reaches the Siwa Paraitonion.
It was still another 300 kilometers
along the coast to Alexandria.
Geologists will tell you,
even if not asked that
Oasis is a misnomer.
These are depressions in the
high desert plateau where the
ground level is several hundred
meters closer to the water
table than on the plateau.
Next slide please.
In pre-history and early history,
there were artesian Springs.
At the Roman period water
depended on extraction
via wells and cannots
those underground channels
running downhill from aquifers.
Next slide, please.
Only the area around these
water sources are there outlets
can be cultivated and would meet
the modern concept of an Oasis.
There are many, many such
smaller oases in each depression,
but this theological purism
does not actually correspond to
the meaning of Oasis and
either Egyptian or Greek,
just as an English.
The ancients used it as we do to refer
to the whole of a depression.
My focus will be on the Oasis
and their relationship to
Egypt that is the Nile valley.
In other words,
on the Oasis as destinations
and points of origin for
caravan traffic as
producers and consumers,
the degree to which they
were also waste stations
on longer caravan routes
and thus more analogous
to the classic caravan cities
as Rostovtzeff's book
portrayed them has been
debated to the south.
The focus has been on
the route later known
as the Dab Al Dabain the 40 days track,
which in the medieval and
Ottoman periods was a major route
for trade in gold and slaves
from Sub-Saharan Africa
to the Mediterranean.
It ran south from the tip of
the Kharga Oasis to Darfur,
but its use is not clearly attested
before the medieval period.
That does not mean it was not at all.
We should be open to the
kind of re-evaluation that
Andrew Wilson has brought
to trans Saharan trade through the Fazan
But even that was not as Wilson
has shown a through trade
route driven by demand in
Africa or in the Roman world.
As in later times,
rather it involved the need
on the part of the Garamantian
agricultural civilization to
export it surplus and import
what it lacked.
The Garamantians did
not pass on Roman goods
to its trading partners to the south.
The residents of the Egyptian
oases are the counterparts
of the Garamantians.
With connections to the west.
We are somewhat better informed.
Already in the fifth
century, a route between
the Fazan and Siwa via
our Algila is attested by
Haraditus taking, we're
told about 20 days.
Next slide, please.
It is for reasons I shall come
to not likely this route was
in use much before that
time from Siwa, of course,
one could then reach Baharia
And from there the volume
in the Nile valley,
one medieval source places the
Fazan at 60 days travel via
this route to Cairo, perhaps
a slight exaggeration.
There is very little evidence
whether literary documentary
or archaeological for active
traffic along this route in the
Roman period.
The very scarce spines of
African red slip wares and the
great Oasis tell us
nothing about the route
by which they arrived,
which is at least as likely
to have been by coastal trade
from Tunisia, transport up
the Nile and Oasis traffic
with the valley, as it is
directly across the desert
via Siwa and the chain of Oasis.
And there's nothing so far
identified in the fines or
culture of the Oases to suggest
strong connections across
the Sahara or with Libyan
nomadic populations.
The possibilities of economic
life in the Oasis were driven
above all by two constraints
that were also opportunities,
water and distance.
We'll talk further about each of these,
but first it is worth
reflecting briefly on the other
resources that the
Oases has had or lacked,
they had soil from the breakdown
of rock and from solids
and irrigation water,
but it was at perennial risk
of destruction either by the
occasional flash flood,
something documented Aldare
in the Kharga Oasis or more
commonly by being blown
away by the north wind,
a perennial fact of life,
but apparently more vigorous
in some periods than others.
We had probably lost more than
a meter of ancient settlement
debris at M Hayden.
The site in Dakhla
where I have directed an
excavation since 2004,
retaining agricultural soils
was thus a permanent challenge.
There was however, plenty of sand.
This is perhaps not a surprise to anyone,
but it should not be taken for granted.
The same north wind that carries
away top soil brings down
sand dunes from the plateau
into the Oasis depressions and
moves them steadily
southward at a good clip
about seven meters a year.
As we have measured it at M heda.
Next slide, please.
These dunes vary in size,
but some are very large.
This will give you an idea of the scale.
The next slide please.
Plantations such as orchards.
The agricultural middle-class
seems not to have existed
sixth, instead we find
landlords from tenants,
but not as in the valley
tenants with some independence
negotiating time, limited leases,
rather tenants apparently
existing in continuing dependent
relationships with the
owners of the Wells.
And of course in this context,
landlord means someone who
controls water and extracts rent
from it.
And seventh,
the capitalists behind the
Wells were to some degree
absentees.
Some of them undoubtedly
lived in Hibis Memphis,
which is the capital of Bahariya
but others lived in the valley.
They depended on a managerial
class at multiple levels,
much as the wealthiest
landlords in the valley.
The higher managers might well
even be members of the city
council themselves.
And some of them may have
owned shares and Wells too.
The terminology of our texts does not
make it easy to tease out
these complex and
hierarchical relationships.
But we can at least say that
management played a larger role
in the economy than regions
where independent farmers and
small urban landowners were
major factors as they were in
the valley.
These managers were of necessity literate.
So education was needed.
Now some second order consequences,
the written documentation from the Oases
before the fourth century
is relatively scanty.
And the fourth century and
beginning of the fifth also
formed the period best
known from archeology.
For various reasons
I do not think this was the
most prosperous period of these
islands of habitation and
the picture I'm giving of the
society of the Oasis is largely
of its last phase before
a rapid decline with the
abandonment of many sites,
it is possible that things were
somewhat different than the
first three centuries of Roman rule,
but because the underlying
structural basis of the society
was already present from the
start of the Roman period,
if not before, I think that most of
what I am saying about it was true
throughout the Imperial period.
I've argued that the society
lacked the great middle groups
that we know from
Ptolemaic enrollment Egypt.
On the one hand,
the traditional Royal farmers
are public farmers with
long-term tenancy of land
owned by the crown or the state
enjoying many protections
on stability of conditions.
They had paid a relatively high
proportion of their crop to
the state and it doesn't matter whether
we call that rent or
tax, but the state knew
that its revenues dependent
in large part on this population.
And it usually made sure that
they were not dispossessed
or seized for debt.
Creditors could not take their land.
On the other hand,
perhaps a third of the rural
population owned their own
farms of sufficient size
to support a family.
These two groups are not
attested in the Oasis.
What we have instead is
five important groups.
First, the tenants working the
land, watered by the Wells.
We know them almost
entirely, (Roger coughs)
excuse me, from texts,
mainly Ostrica and the Kelis account book,
which mentioned them in
connection with the products of
these Wells, particularly on brief texts,
written as tags from jars of wine.
The next slide, please.
Second, the transport workers
whose importance I've already stressed,
donkey drivers and camel
drivers responsible for
the raising care and
exploitation of these animals,
as well as wagon ears, third
artisans and service personnel,
mostly of groups
well-known from the valley.
Potters, smith's builders,
furniture makers,
cobblers, Lyndon weavers,
buller's, millers,
retail merchants, bath
attendance, locksmiths,
butchers, tailors, undertakers,
and the like along with
the more distinctive Oasis
occupation of well cleaner.
Fourth the managers,
both the local agents well-known
from the documents and the
higher level supervisors
and fifth, the capitalists,
mostly landlords goo quiet.
They were called and we call
them except that water Lords
might be more descriptive or tree Lords.
And also some lenders who
financed caravan trips to and from
the valley.
This last group is barely known to us
from a couple of contracts
next slide please.
And they may have,
in some cases have been the
same as the owners of wells,
but in many instances,
they were probably intermediaries
between the landlords and
the transporters serving
in effect as brokers.
In this society of the missing
middle is filled mainly
with artisans and managers,
perhaps the transport
workers also belong here,
but I do not think so.
Those whose names are given
all have Egyptian names.
This might seem unimportant,
but it is not when Rodney Austin
and I analyzed the two key
populations of the Trimithis Ostrica cup.
We found that the tenants whose
names appeared on the wine
jar tags virtually all had Egyptian names.
Next slide, please.
The managers in contrast,
almost all had Greek or Roman names.
The next slide, please.
The contrast is stark.
And I must admit that it surprised us.
We are accustomed to great
caution in the use of names as
evidence after 600 years of
Greek and Roman rule with all of
the cultural complexity that
this brought not to speak of
intermarriage of the immigrant
populations with locals.
In the valley, we do not find
such stark differences in naming.
Now we know nothing of the
genetic background of these Oases
groups in the fourth century oases,
but from a cultural standpoint,
it is clear that they are very distinct.
The managerial class with
its classical education,
for which we have a lot
of evidence in oases
names its children,
accordingly, next slide please.
And this at least ought to
make the class assists in the
audience, feel at home,
even if Egypt is otherwise alien to them,
just to be clear,
I will say that I'm not suggesting
that we should return to
the view of each Egypt
a protal feudal society,
that pepper ecologists have
been struggling to escape ever
since H.I Bill put it
forward a century ago.
Most historians today would
accept the view that late
antique Egypt was a more unequal
society than Hellenistic or
early Roman Egypt.
And that this inequality
rested to a large degree on an
increased concentration of land ownership,
but the rest of the legal and
social baggage of Bell's proto
feudalism is no longer alive
in contemporary scholarship.
In the Oasis land ownership
per se is not at stake.
It is Wells and investment
in long maturing tree crops
that are critical.
This capital intensive economy
does share with the valley
a larger role for
investment in infrastructure
and a monetized market
for high value crops
than was true in the Egypt
of an earlier period.
But because of the water
regime and distance,
as a far pure instance of a
capital dominated society.
We have no data to allow us
to measure inequality in this
society, I cannot offer any
Gini coefficients, alas,
but let us look at one
indicator that to my mind
is significant illegitimacy.
I've discussed this more fully elsewhere.
Reassessing the argument
made by Herbert Judy
a half century ago that
illegitimacy in the Pyri
of Roman Egypt reflects
marriage restrictions imposed
by the Roman government rather
than as he put it the loose morals
of a low class population.
Now the negative side of his
case is strong people with only
a mother's name appear
wherever the evidence allows
us to say to come from
stable domestic relationships
in which the parents simply
are not legally married.
The positive side of his
argument, however does not stand.
The use of mother's names for
identification persists long
after the disappearance of the prohibition
on soldiers marriages,
or on inter marriage and long
after the nine constitution.
It is rather I've argued the
product of a society with
significant economic
inequalities that allow men
of greater means to have families,
perhaps second families with
what we would call concubines.
As it happens there's a lot
of evidence for illegitimacy
in the Oasis texts,
both in the third to fourth
century archive for the funeral
workers of and in the
Austriacus from Kelis.
And Trimithis the incidence
of illegitimacy appears
to be higher than in
contemporary archives valley.
We are of course familiar with
the phenomenon of a society
in which the economically
disadvantaged are less likely to
marry than those of
higher economic status.
We live in it,
but perhaps even more striking
is the picture that I have
sketched of the Oasis.
And equally familiar to us today
is the role of elite education
in reproducing inequality from generation
to generation that the wealthy
of Roman Egypt supported
classical education for
their male offspring
is by now well-documented.
And we know quite a lot about
that educational process.
What is more striking is
the link between classical
education and the managerial
ranks not only at the top,
but at the local level,
the close similarity of the
handwriting of the manager
who maintained the Kelis account book.
And that if one of the writers
of the codex of I Socrates
tablets found in the same
room is not an accident
in the recent publication
of a fourth century,
codex of mathematical
problems in sample contracts.
The next slide, please,
Alexander Johnson and I have
argued that it is a witness
to the deliberate formation of managers.
The school of management
attended after a primary and even
secondary education in the classics.
There is no investment
without risk and the wealthy
residents of the valley who
invested in adding to the stock
of Wells and the Oasis in the
early years under Roman rule
must have taken account of the risks
that they could recognize at the time.
These may not have been
entirely the same as those that
affected investment decisions
in the fourth century,
it was difficult
to separate out a recognition
of risks from an attempt
to understand why the
Oasis declined steeply
in late antiquity.
Across Dakhla there is a
horizon of abandonment,
or at least partial
abandonment in the 360s,
and to reduce level of
occupation afterward,
we have less good information for Kharga
but at least the Southern
part of that Oasis has little
to show after the first
decades of the fifth century,
much the same as true of Baharia.
There are four main potential
risks that I can see.
The first is the possibility that Wells
will stop producing water or require
so much deepening that they're
no longer economically viable.
Today's mechanized drilling
can reach lower aquifers than
the ancient were capable of tapping.
We do not know what the
lifespan of an ancient well was.
I do not see how, except with
unlikely extensive excavation,
excuse me, we will ever find out.
A second risk is markets.
If demand for Oasis products
were to fall or prices to
soften because of increased
competition from cultivation in
the Highlander, along the valley,
the profitability of the
enterprise could be threatened
because high transportation costs
would he rode profit margins
and harm competitiveness.
Third risk is the security of the oases.
We do know in fact that there
were some attacks on Kharga
in later centuries and
insecurity may have started
to be a factor in the third century.
It was under the tetrarchy that
the first permanent military
installations in the Oases appear
to have been built more
or less simultaneously
in Baharia, Dakhla and Kharga.
Next slide, please,
whether these were responding
to pass the tax or represent a
more forward-looking
apprehension, we do not know.
There is next to no documentation
of desert insecurity in this period.
Finally, it is also
possible that the insecurity
of lines of communication,
the caravan routes themselves might
have threatened commerce.
Even if the oases themselves were secure,
there is no chain of military posts
in the desert to secure the roads.
And we have no way of if
increasing attacks on caravans
might have raised effective
cost of goods beyond
what it was possible to recover
in the markets of the valley.
In effect, even without
any system of insurance,
the risk level for caravan
lands may have risen beyond
the bearable levels.
We lack the data to assess the
contribution that these risks
may do abandonment and
thus investment failure
in the fourth and fifth centuries,
the relative speed and
simultaneity of abandonment at
different sites in Dakhla in the 360s,
makes me doubt that failure
of the Wells was at stake.
It is not likely that the water level
would have fallen so rapidly.
And in so many different areas.
The lifespan of Wells may
well have caused investors
to factor that in when looking at return,
but it is not likely to have been a source
of catastrophic risk.
Shifts in prices and
competitiveness are also not
likely to have been so sunken though
they may indeed have happened.
For these reasons I believe security
is a more likely candidate,
but whether the Oasis
were directly attacked
and there is no evidence for
this in the fourth century
and the abandoned sites show,
no sign of disturbance
or the caravan routes
were subject to plundering.
It is hard to say.
We also cannot at this point
say whether investors could
have seen these risks coming
already a century earlier,
or if they became visible only suddenly
in the middle of the fourth century,
nor yet do we know how long
the Roman army remained
in the oases spots.
They were certainly
still there in the 360s,
but for how much longer is not clear.
Quses in south Kharga probably
still had some soldiers
in the first two decades
of the early fifth century,
but it was not a major Garrison site.
A lot of things had to come together
for the economic growth visible
in the Oasis in the Roman
period to have been possible.
And obviously they did,
most of them had been in place
already for a half millennium
and they had undeniably led
to an expansion of settlement,
water technology, a long
distance transportation,
a distinctive niche in the
production of valuable crops.
It's possible that the Roman
period brought new crops in the
form of cotton and perhaps
millet, but above all,
it brought a tax regime favorable
to the investment of private capital.
That capital found the combination
of the other factors attractive.
It was not until the Egyptian
government in the time of
Nassar decided to expand
settlement in the Oasis that the
oases would again be as densely
settled as in Roman times,
but that visible prosperity
came at a human cost.
Part of that cost was a
high level of inequality
and a segmentation of the population.
Very different from what
we find in the Nile valley.
The key to the viability of the system
was a state management,
and that was possible only with
the literate tools required
for recordkeeping and reporting.
Teachers of the classics
found a ready audience
in the future agents of capital.
You can draw any moral for yourself.
Thank you.
- Possibly the sound of one
hand clapping there Roger,
thank you so much.
I think Joe is going to
take help manage questions.
How do you wanna do it, Joe?
- I think if you, if you
all don't mind questions via
the chat so I can,
with my colleagues fill them
maybe consolidate a fill them
to get together in a good single question.
That sort of thing, just to,
we don't bombard Roger
from all over the place.
So if you don't mind, we'll
let Roger rest for 30 seconds,
catch his breath, then send your questions
via the chat, please.
- In the meantime, I should,
I can say what I should've said
at the beginning that it is
actually Rostovzteff's
a 150th birthday today.
So well done.
- Maybe Roger just myself,
to get things going for a few
minutes and ask you about the
current work that you're
doing out there and
what is on your research agenda
that you are looking for
that might help flesh out
this rise in decline story in the oases,
which is rather dramatic?
- Oh, well, we'd like to
keep digging of course.
And as anybody who works in Egypt knows
that's been impossible in recent years
to get permission to
excavate in the Oasis.
They are in the military zone
and the military has not been
giving permission,
even though our permission
from the Antiquities Ministry
has come through every year.
We have not actually been
able to go out and dig.
At the point that we were stopped.
We were beginning a house
excavated house that is much
larger than the rather
large and lavish house
that we excavated at the beginning,
the house of Serenas with its
wall painting and so forth.
And this larger house I think
has got to be at least twice,
if not three times the size of
sereneness with much grander
and better built banquet hall
and a lot of wall paintings
and much, much higher quality plaster,
moldings and stuff like this.
So I would like to know whose that is.
It has an enormous number
of Austriacus well tags,
these labels from wine jars
that we found in the first year
we dug in and that was the
last year we were able to work.
So we have a huge amount
still to do in that house.
And we would really
love to get back to it,
to get another person from that
upper end of society at the
same time, there's a lot more
to be done in humbler areas.
And there's an area that seems
to be a century older than
these houses in another part
of the site that we surveyed.
So some years ago, after
the dunes, March, south,
and uncovered it for us where
we would like also to work
because that area looks to have
much more like what we would
think of as Roman urban planning,
but the houses are also more
modest and we'd like to see
what kind of people live there to get a
a better sense of
is there really a middle
class that we're just totally
missing up to this point
from the sites that we've worked at?
The Egyptians have also been
working at another site.
I know Seville, which has yielded Ostrica.
That seemed pretty much to
reflect the kind of dare I say it
today, plantation economy
that I've been describing.
And if we were able to work in Dakhla
it would be a lot easier to
collaborate with them because
they've been very open about
allowing us to work on the
documents they've found.
- Okay, the questions are
kind of rolling in now.
So if I may, let me get to some of them.
Bear with me, could a
shift from bank credit
in the third century CE
to peer-to-peer credit
in the fifth and sixth century CE
have been a factor in decline.
- I know that peer-to-peer credit
would have been a factor in decline.
We certainly do find it
in earlier centuries.
That's just that we find
more of it and we don't.
And I don't think we find
significant bank credit
in that fashion at all.
Actually, I don't think that
credit was in short supply,
but it's possible that the
water Lords were more rapacious
with it and it's really very hard to say
because we don't have
the comparable documents
from the earlier period.
So we don't see credit
transactions happening in the Oasis
in an earlier time.
- If the basis of the inequality
was structurally different,
how did this express itself, was it last,
more simply shifted?
Do you think it felt
qualitatively different?
- I'm sorry, I didn't didn't
hear that clearly Joe.
- If the basis of the inequality
was structurally different,
how did this express itself,
was it less more simply shifted?
Do you think it felt
qualitatively different?
- Well, I think the missing middle
made it qualitatively different.
We didn't have as much of a continuum
from the poor to the rich
the Gulf was much wider and
the managers were, if anything,
on the rich side of that divide, right?
Because they got educated and
no doubt took off their share
of the revenues.
Whereas I think the transporters
were probably on the wrong
side of that line, but
without the middle group,
I think that the extremity of it.
The quantity is the quality in that sense.
- Do we have any contracts governing
the tenancy arrangements
where these bound tenants
at scripted, where they paid wages,
where they debt slaves also
tree crop production is often
highly labor intensive water
lifting costs and so on.
Do we have evidence of slave labor?
- There is certainly evidence
for slavery in the oases,
but not as far as I know for
slave labor in agriculture,
we have no tenancy contracts.
And if I remember correctly,
no real labor contracts,
either what we have is on the one hand,
the labels coming in on the line jars,
showing who the tenants were.
And on the other hand, the
rent rolls in the account book,
which were set up with
the names of the tenants,
which basically are the same
from year to year over a
three-year period and
laid down in advance,
the amount of rent that
was expected from them,
and then entries made
as they made payments.
So it looks to have been an
extremely stable situation with
not a lot of variety from year to year
and probably not much flux at all.
This suggests to me a
situation in which the tenants
had very limited agency.
- Two questions after my
own heart at the moment.
What about climate change
or disease as factors in decline, Roger.
- Sorry, climate change, or what?
what was the second one?
- [Joe] Or Disease
- Disease, yes,
it's very likely that the
Oases were affected as the rest
of Egypt was by the end of
the Roman climatic optimum,
but because the water
came from underground
and had been laid down
thousands of years earlier,
it is not to have been affected
in the way that the valley
was by changes in the Nile flood
as a result of rainfall patterns shifting.
So I doubt that that
climate change is likely
to have made a lot of difference.
I don't think changes in
temperature would have been
particularly harmful because
the Oases are in general,
hotter than the valley anyway.
So if they'd cooled off just a few degrees
in the fourth century,
that probably would've been a good thing
from their point of view.
Disease is harder to say there certainly
was plenty of disease
and also plenty of trauma
that we can find from the
work of the bio archeologists
at Kelis in particular, but also at Aldair
and at Labaca in Kharga.
But the chronology of the
burials is not precise
enough as far as I can see to
give us a sense of change over
time in what diseases were there
and the diseases that they have found
mostly don't look as if they are likely
to have been specific
epidemics, let us say,
I don't think we've got enough evidence
for the second half of the second century
to hope to nail smallpox there.
And on the other hand,
we don't have cemeteries excavated so far
that date to the sixth century,
where we might find bubonic plague.
So most of the evidence that we have
is in a chronological fork
that's not favorable to
finding that evidence.
- Who owned the camels?
Hello, Jim.
- That is very hard to say actually it.
- And operators hire drivers
in the trucking industry.
So can we differentiate?
- Yeah it is perfectly
possible that those existed
that some of the camels belonged
to the capitalists and that they
then that they hired Camel drivers
to send their stuff to their markets.
On the other hand,
they contracts in Genoa that
I republished in the Gusscu
festschrift it looks as if the
transporters are themselves,
the camel owners, and they
are kind of independent agents
contracting with a
capitalist for the journey.
There's a lot, that's unclear in those.
They're not very well drafted,
but it looks as if that is more nearly
an arm's length relationship,
even though the same
people clearly contracted
in more than one year.
- If you would take
one more question maybe
at the late hour here,
what were the unique characteristics
of the share contracts
between the water Lords and
water infrastructure ownership
compared to other sorts of proto
corporative contracts found
in other parts of Egypt or
the rest of the Mediterranean?
- Sorry, I lost the second half of that.
- Were there any unique characteristics
of the shared contracts
between the water Lords
and the water infrastructure
ownership compared
to other sources proto
corporative contracts
found in other parts of Egypt
or the rest of the Mediterranean?
- Unfortunately, we
don't have the contracts
between the water Lords and the tenants.
All we have is the evidence
in the rent rolls of what was
going on from year to year.
So we are left pretty much to guess from
this external evidence
at what the nature of
the relationship might be,
this is deeply regrettable.
I would love to have
that kind of evidence,
but it really looks as if it
is something close to customary
and even hereditary tendency.
There's one case where
it looks as if it passes
from one member of a family to another,
between two years and the account book.
So I suspect it's very much in
that kind of hereditary frame.
- Okay well, Roger, thank you so much.
I think I'd turn it over
to our chair, Chris,
who would invite us for
a wonderful cocktail
in front of a beautiful
fireplace (Joe laughs)
in new Haven, but.
- I'm gonna go have a glass of Bandol.
- That sounds very nice.
I actually asked Noel if he
would just do the end bit.
- Oh yeah, okay.
- I'm happy to chime in here
after such a wonderful lecture.
And right before the lecture began,
I had sent an email to
Roger and some of the other
co-organizers talking
about how on some level,
I think we probably all feel
like we've been living in Oasis
since last March.
All of us isolated in our little enclaves,
hopefully with family and friends,
but in so far as that's true,
I can say that this evening,
at least we've witnessed
Roger kind of bring us drinks
of cool intellectual water
and moreover to do things
in a manner that didn't obtain
in the Western oases in so
far as he's been so generous.
He's not a capitalist with his knowledge.
He's great at sharing it out.
So I think we can thank
him very much for all that
he's taught us tonight and all
that he's done to enlighten us.
- [Roger] Thank.
- And we should know that we
hope to have the host Rodger in
the fall, in the Beinecke
to have a kind of a,
a pro seminar with Papyri
actually in person.
We are keeping fingers crossed on that.
- Inshallah.
- [Joe] Inshallah. Yeah.
- Goodnight, everyone.
- [Roger] All right.
- Thank you so much.
It's nice to see old
friends and new friends.